[Música]
cuando tenía dos años no había muchas
cosas para hacer en los veranos hasta
que un día llegó mi papá del trabajo con
un formulario para inscribirme a la
colonia de verano en una de primeras
tardes en el club entrar a la historia
de la pileta y me quedé paralizado
había un adolescente saltando de banco
en banco desnudo y riéndose a carcajadas
intentando pegarle a sus compañeros con
una toalla mojada
esta persona tenía cara diferente al
resto y le costaba hablar
sin hacer mucho ruido me acerque un
amigo y le pregunté si quién es que no
lo conoces de juan pablo
y que tiene tiene down
en ese momento me sentí bastante perdido
y con miedo
a mi función y edad nadie me había
hablado específicamente de la
discapacidad y mucho menos del síndrome
de down era uno de esos temas que no se
hablaban mucho pero bueno pasaban los
días la colonia de verano y juan pablo
no paraba de sorprenderme para bien o
para mal en algunos casos venía
corriendo rápido hacia vos y te empujaba
y de repente gritaba te abrazaba y tesón
raya juan piedras y una caja de
sorpresas
lo bueno de pasar largos veranos ahí ir
aquí todos los días y aprendiendo un
poco más acerca de juanvi
ese fue mi primer contacto con la
discapacidad ahí comencé a naturalizar
la convivencia lo que me generó una
afinidad con el síndrome
ese fue un recuerdo que tuve guardado lo
largo de los años
ya mucho tiempo después con 33 años me
encontraba bastante quejo soy crítico de
muchas cosas que pasaban en la sociedad
me di cuenta que la frase que más salida
de mi boca era como puede ser que como
puede ser que como puede ser que en esos
días hablando con un amigo me contaba
todas las cosas que tenía que superar a
diario con su hijo con síndrome de dawn
hacer una peregrinación colegio por
colegio intentando conseguirle un banco
pelear para que sea aceptado en la
prepaga ser incluido en la escuela de
fútbol del barrio y mil cosas más
me puse en el lugar de ese papá
lo triste que es rogar para que tu hijo
sea aceptado
es me partió el alma me generó muchísima
impotencia
la cruda realidad de superar barreras
sociales todo el tiempo
imagínense lo desgastante que es eso
para una familia
y ese día me quedé pensando y pensando
en esa injusticia y en cómo poder
cambiar ese realidad
se me ocurrió que ofreciendo actividades
podríamos cambiar en la vida personas
con discapacidad
me apasioné de la idea cuando hice fue
tomando su arma me enamoré del proyecto
y recuerdo aquel inolvidable
16 de febrero del 2017 ahí nació
fundación empate
donde acompañamos potenciamos el
desarrollo de personas a través de
actividades deportivas culturales y
laborales
ese día me enamoré del síndrome de dawn
comienza empate a los veces llegue
ezequiel a la actividad de fútbol una
persona de unos 30 años o metro 50 sin
decir una palabra y con su mirada
clavada en el piso en una de sus manos
sujetaba la de su papá y la otra un
viejo más sube cartas
hola como estan soy germán o la german
como estas nos contaron de este lugar y
que haríamos que ezequiel pruebe a ver
si puede y le gusta claro que sí que
hizo ezequiel en estos 30 años
su papá con una mirada un poco perdida y
esta vergonzosa me respondió no no no
mucho y sé que no sale mucho de nuestra
casa y juega con su mazo de cartas y no
te hagas problema ningún problema
déjalo con nosotros para que empiece la
clase vamos s
sin ni siquiera dar un paso ezequiel se
ancló con una mula empacada
mira su papá y me dijo no no no no no sé
quién no sabe correr
ahí comenzamos una hermosa etapa
empezando desde cero con un trabajo de
hormiga
ese día recuerdo logramos dar dos
vueltas a la cancha caminando muy
despacito
muchas veces se me hace difícil explicar
qué es fundación empate
creo que solamente te das cuenta cuando
estás allá adentro y te toca vivirlo de
cerca
es muy fuerte cuando los voluntarios te
cuentan sobre cómo te cambia la forma de
ver la vida y lo gratificante que es
dedicar tu tiempo para el desarrollo de
otra persona
todos los que forman parte entendemos
cuál es la filosofía de empate
en la sociedad tenemos estereotipos que
nos inculcan el tener que ganar en todo
momento lo cual nos genera una gran
presión o lo crítico y trágico de perder
la derrota
es ahí cuando tomas fuerza el concepto
en váter
empatando todo está bien
entendiendo que empatando estamos
ganando estamos ganando en igualdad en
oportunidades en derechos
en empate
exigimos a nuestros alumnos como si no
tuviesen discapacidad
de esta manera potenciamos su desarrollo
y el techo se lo ponen ellos mismos
esa es la metodología de empate no
sobreproteger sino todo lo contrario
brindar herramientas y empoderar a la
persona para que quiera y pueda lograr
lo que decida
como el caso de ezequiel se acuerdan de
ezequiel quien en su primera clase no
soltaba a su viejo mazo de cartas
después de muchos meses de trabajo y de
paciencia
ezequiel fue confiando en su entorno en
sus compañeros en sus profesores y por
sobre todo en el mismo
en una de las clases vimos como ezequiel
realizaba un circuito de coordinación
por sí solo sin la ayuda de ningún
voluntario
saltaba dentro de un aro saltaba dentro
de otro de otro hacía zigzag entre los
conos salta una malla y terminaba el
ejercicio pegándole a la pelota
a esto lo conté muchísimas veces y se me
sigue acelerando el corazón
nos dimos cuenta que el costado de la
cancha estaba su papá con los ojos
llenos de lágrimas
se nos acercó y nos dijo
gracias a todos ustedes por permitir que
ezequiel a sus 30 años aprenda cosas
nuevas
ese día me di cuenta de la importancia y
la confianza de confiar mutuamente y
tomar como propio el proceso de ezequiel
así como me enamoré cuando comenzamos
con la fundación
ese día cuando viese a quien superarse
él mismo me di cuenta que me des enamoré
del síndrome de dawn
me dicen amor
y me enamoré ezequiel del aura de
lautaro de mariah de daniel
personas a los que todos los días les
damos herramientas para que puedan
desarrollarse como personas íntegras
independientes de su condición
es muy común
y lo desconocido nos genera
incertidumbre
muchas veces observo reacciones de
desconcierto que tiene la gente cuando
tiene que interactuar con la
discapacidad
según el paso muchos de ustedes
situaciones donde se quedaron como
recalculando
me pasó una vez que quede totalmente
desconcertado al tener que saludar por
primera vez dándole la mano a una
persona si llega
cómo reaccionar a un abrazo inesperado
de una persona con síndrome de dawn
o cómo responder a una pregunta incómoda
sincera de una persona con asperger o
con qué fuerza empujar la silla de
ruedas de una persona que nos está
pidiendo ayuda
a mí esas situaciones me pasaron y me
van a seguir pasando
nadie juzga a nadie ante el
desconocimiento de no saber cómo
interactuar con la discapacidad
qué es ser normal
a veces solo queremos actuar normal
cuando nadie es normal
porque comportarnos de la misma manera
cuando todos somos diferentes
forzando situaciones en lugar de
naturalizar la convivencia
no sea miedo en la discapacidad
nos pone en una situación incómoda
escuchar discapacidad no
les cuento una anécdota
estábamos por comenzar la entrada en
calor de la clase de fútbol cuando
observo un alumno que se estaba
friccionando en su tobillo con cara de
dolor
me acerqué y le pregunté qué pasó
estoy muy hinchado
ok recuerda que no hace la entrada en
calor luego no puede entrenar
mágicamente se le desaparece la
jiennense y empezó a correr sin ningún
problema
eso es empatar
square más allá de la discapacidad
significa no consentir ni sobre proteger
al alumno sino que hacerle entender que
la entrada en calor es una parte
importante del entrenamiento
exigirle como cualquier otra persona
ahí está la inclusión
ahora
pueden ustedes ser aliados de la
filosofía de empatar en el día a día
claro que sí
empatar significa mirar por igual a la
persona con discapacidad cuando le
cruzamos en la calle
ser respetuosos
ser pacientes
ser empáticos
de esta manera ustedes también están
empatando en la vida
tenemos que dejar de romantizar a la
discapacidad de camuflarla le llaman los
angelitos personitas especiales seres
con capacidades diferentes
tenemos que lograr entre todos que no
nos dé miedo decir la palabra de
discapacidad entendiendo que aceptando
las diversidades todos podemos tener
oportunidades que hoy en definitiva lo
que necesitamos para ser protagonistas
de nuestra propia historia
empecemos a empatar
[Música]